way too much money on uh
that wasn't jared van der uh no that was
a couple weeks ago um
oh against uh the guy with the flat face
yes what the hell he's from alabama
he's from alabama
[Music]
there you go so i mean do blood tests
now and see what your you know what you
need nutritionally
every time i went everything was normal
and up to date my irons all i take like
three
big capsules of vitamins every day and
sorry never mind what i said you don't
need vegetables just keep doing what
you're doing bro yeah don't listen to
chicken
so it's just proteins yeah i eat like
proteins and likes
more like natural fats like nuts and
yeah sometimes i have beans like in like
a salad like a something fun or
something that's like the most
sustainable vegetables so welcome to
cats after dark uh you're just joining
us as chin who hasn't recently lost 300
pounds is giving nutritional advice to
george but i i did at one point
just kidding oh yeah you were you were
big i was like almost 300. brandon
always says i was 300. i'm not that
wasn't ever three hundred and something
twelve
forty-one too
volkanovsky that's insane no he was two
fourteen but oh okay brandon kept saying
that one i've ever i've heard 240 a lot
and i think it was i i think honestly
rogan yeah it was joe way back in the
day um 214 was the highest yeah that's
so much different
yeah
like with his frame there too like
that's that's a lot well how tall are
you chen
i think i'm six two but brendan says i'm
six three
so because he's because when we stand
next to each other he says he's six four
i'm like right almost right there yeah
have you ever seen have you seen this
picture i think i saw one picture yeah
did you have a more of a shaved head in
this like i probably period maybe i did
there's one specific picture
i'm trying to find it all right yeah
it's way back in your instagram i mean
which which one you talking about the
one it's like a prom photo oh it looks
like you just [ __ ] some girl off the
emperor's shape building no look i look
like a ventriloquist yeah
it looks like i could please find that
oh my god it seriously looks
photoshopped it's it's insane and it's a
very funny photo and you lost the weight
by how
pretty much what george is doing cut out
sugar no i'm all suffering
i enjoyed every time i got to eat but i
only ate really tiny small meals only
once or twice a day
it was really really good look at that
hunker hunker was that my phone oh my
god i'm not sure does it look like i'm a
petroleum it looks like i have my arm in
her back and i can make her talk what oh
yeah you can make things like that you
know what i'm saying it looks like it
i'm not even joking it looks so crazy
that you look like the creepiest
ventriloquist
is this a sears
hawkins dance yeah you guys had sadie
hawkins dance yeah and i thought that
was just
your dance yeah that was my date and
imagine that being my date i'm like so
giant and she's so tiny yeah yeah and
it's a sadie hawkins dancer she asked
you oh is that a throwback picture that
you posted this one which one this was
this a throwback because i was thinking
oh that was a selfie dude i love this
guy yeah it's a program look at this tbt
yeah yeah that was the picture that's
crazy
so i can't quit
what happened is that why cat quit
you were talking for her you had your
hand in her back look at it
yeah let's let's uh scroll a little bit
through more hey man no there's like
memories in there i don't want to see
right now
oh wait wait how about that the will
ferrell one where go up a little bit
more in it a little bit higher right
there are you trying wilfred john c
rowell on the right over here i didn't
see this one yeah i did see this one
my former boss fired me from by the way
they came for funny or die
yeah to do the song that david bowie
christmas song
i forgot what it was but
it's a very famous song oh okay okay and
this is our boy trevor yeah trevor who
actually we should have on we should
be fun the man behind a lot of the songs
oh ton of the songs that yeah you guys
are doing dude most of our stuff he
produces engineers he did stuff for lana
del rey he's he's really talking about
the savage garden yeah he's gonna be on
tour with that guy the lead
singer darren oh trevor usada trevor
usada usada that's [ __ ] united states
anti-doping
what's his last name
yesuda oh either way
i heard john jones
there you go
uh yeah we should have him on he's very
very very talented man and uh the guy
from savage garden darren whatever his
name is there he's right there in the
very right he put like a
a post on his instagram darren was like
congratulatory yeah yeah uh
nick told me about this it was like just
honoring trevor like on his instagram
one post just like
it
seemed like i've never done that for
like a significant other right
it was so beautiful wait when you go
back to that picture you just clicked on
the blue background
this is amazing they look like the
wiggles or like
yo gabba gabba right here salad yeah
yummy yummy
in my tummy
[Music]
yummy yummy yummy yummy fruits i have no
idea what's going on trevor did a video
with a fruit salad today
it's fun to eat i don't know what's
going on with this well
i obviously don't know the whole thing
just let it run its course i'll stop the
pre-chorus he did do something with the
wig he uh no no no not the wiggles
that'd be awesome but actually the kid
leroy do you guys know who that is yeah
yeah yeah okay leroy is like a really
big singer right now to our generation
yeah yeah the only person he brings out
of his show he brought him out in
australia was the wiggles which is like
a legendary thing like he has songs with
justin bieber all these people he's like
special guests and the wiggles come out
what are the wiggles so they're they're
like they're a chill they're four dudes
children's group
and they sing like
songs about like fruit salad but they're
they're enormous to the point they sell
out arenas and they've been doing it for
like
25 years
well
[Music]
i love how they open the mosh pit for
the
[ __ ] one big wiggles hell yeah oh yeah
i'll mess it up
open that up
look how about y'all just complying yes
sir all right first can we please keep
the house lights up
this next guest
[Applause]
[Applause]
there we go a couple members i don't
remember an afro in the woods ladies and
gentlemen the [ __ ] wiggles that's so
dope
have you heard the fruit salad slipknot
remix no
we're about to here i'll text it to you
nick's like i'm about to burn a cd
though
i love slipknot
yes though
there you go
[Laughter]
by the way
i'll tell you about the audio version
why you can't do it sometime soon
later
oh this is just a video
i thought they would actually match it
up they will in a second dude
that song's badass
stop steal your bananas
just scaring kids all across the world
is this the wrong one
toss in some grapes
you want to try the 25 second one if not
which one
whatever has the most moves on
yeah shout out to the [ __ ] wiggles
we're good yeah i don't know it's it's
on the internet somewhere every
everybody check it out uh oh that's just
like we're here to talk here today to
talk about andrew tate all right let's
be honest he's all over our feeds uh i i
you have you heard of this man no andrew
tate you're about i saw okay so i wanna
what i'm on youtube all the time so i
saw andrew tape pop up
on it and that's what happened to me and
i did click on it uh he was on he was on
bffs with dave hortonway a couple weeks
ago he was on uh tom segura and george
said that was like before he blew up
really and then like weeks after he came
so like that's gotten a ton of views and
this man
how did you explain him
i would say captivating
it's crazy because i came in today and i
asked george i'm like have you heard of
andrew tate and he was like oh yeah i
knew your internet kid he'd give me the
lowdown he knew uh and then austin came
in he was like have you heard of cober
tate
he's just that and wildfire everyone has
the same reaction that i asked like my
friends i'll be like do you watch cobra
tate stuff and they all go
i'm subscribed
it's always the same reaction
are you his fight name so this guy is a
full-time world kickboxing champion
which is
kickboxing accolades are always a little
weird you never know how like yeah
anybody can hold insurance all of a
sudden you world champion but he he he
looks cut up he looks like he [ __ ]
knows what he looks like a fighter but
then he's also an internet entrepreneur
he's been hustling for a while but just
in the last six months he kind of
changed his
online strategy yeah and you were
explaining to me so he has a he's taken
over social media and hacked the
algorithm he basically has a
a program called hustlers university
where he teaches like 18 modern wealth
creations so like bitcoin all that type
of stuff but he has people subscribe
and then he has them promote his his
affiliate link and the way you did it or
told me he does it is genius but
currently he said he has 80 so 87 000
monthly subscribers who pay 50 dollars a
month what there's no way i love doing
the math with like patreons and [ __ ]
like tim dillon he's got 40 000 patrons
but that's five dollars a month that's
two hundred thousand dollars a month
yeah
that's 2.4 million dollars a year
80 000 times 50 that's four million
dollars a month
that's
50 million dollars a year just off the
school and then these people who are
paying him
he is also getting to then spread his
like eulogy and spread the affiliate
link back to that course yeah it's they
all like they all create accounts and
then posted videos for him so it's like
marketing everywhere and you can't even
scroll without seeing his stuff on at
least some platform
you said on your flight back this was
great yeah this is the first time i've
seen this like besides sports and stuff
i was on a flight the other day and i
was watching his stuff
i look up the kid in front of me is
watching it and then the kid three rows
in front of me is live streaming him so
like in person i saw like him on
everyone's phones
i was like he's taken over dude this is
crazy it's the first time i've heard of
him i think it's like a also like
because he's like he's very uh
god what's the word perspicacious no
that's what he's doing
eccentric uh
i thought accenture et cetera he has
very uh polarizing views yeah yeah yeah
yeah and and that's sweet of you like
i [ __ ] will have him like he
definitely gets a misogynistic
tone
every once in a while yeah and it's like
and he's like fine you don't have to
believe that but it's definitely
misogynistic he's like oh like women are
women's a man's property because you're
the one who care for him like it's a
little bit dr umar
jesus that guy that just passed away
that would like invite people on his
live streams and like it would be like
explain to me
why women should like you
i remember you know you're talking about
i want i
this is a new segment we have to do
george explains
the internet i don't know
you have to like research like bring in
a video to like show us i am podcast
rain man
my title
uh i but uh that's interesting i want to
look up dr umar but yeah
so he'll he'll take stuff to the
extremes but like i don't know i'm
if there's a line of middle i would say
i'm one foot closer to what he believes
like he believes in gender roles which i
do and like i don't know uh yeah um i
don't know hard work individuality but
then he takes it to a crazy level like
he he considers like regular societal
life like you're plugged into the matrix
he really uses the movie the matrix as a
thing and and you have to become so
wealthy that you're outside the matrix
he has 11 passports and like when there
are covert restrictions he was able to
be a uh he could go in any country he
wants and not wear a mask because he's
that independent i don't know it's yeah
shit's wild and he's making evidently 40
million dollars a month how's that
confirmed though so his patreon channel
actually shows that he gets 50 bucks per
page it's not a patreon it's
his very own website where all the
payment processes have happened so it's
not confirmed okay but the way his [ __ ]
is being spread and he doesn't even have
a ver like his own tick tock account
he's obviously got an army out there
that's doing something
and it's easy to kind of i don't know
like have you ever heard of tai lopez he
was like i remember that yeah
lamborghini i think he was the first
person that like taught everybody how to
like mute post or like i don't want to
see this again because he was on
everybody's facebook feeds but that guy
a lot of people said like he'd rent
stuff to then appear wealthy to then
sell his courses which is something a
lot of people do yeah whereas this guy
he's like
he's adamant that he
was already wealthy and now he is
flashing it to then sell
his class but he was already wealthy he
also got charges against him for like
sex trafficking because he has like a
bunch of women who do only fancy gets a
percentage but i think those chargers
were dropped
it's i just need to say that i'm
entertained by the man so early and i'm
gonna be watching more i'm sure i'll get
sick of him pretty quick pretty soon
yeah i got like a week left probably but
right now he's i'm on i'm honestly yeah
he's so confident and like the way he
speaks so directly it's refreshing to
hear i'm always i'm i'm always uh this
guy rubbed me the wrong way instantly i
didn't like that instantly for me
he when i worked at the adam carolla
show
hands down brought in the biggest
entourage anyone's ever brought in the
show he had like 18 people way too many
people you know when you know when uh
um
in zoolander ben stiller goes and he
hides at like
hansel's
and there's just all these like weird
kind of like hipster that's the group of
people tai lopez they're all like dark
and brooding and yeah oh
yeah so ty is really cool
with no
you're like what are all you people
doing
but the man read a book a day
damn that's what he says yeah
you want to know how i got this
knowledge
well you definitely wrote
this knowledge he definitely read books
wait you said he has sex trafficking and
he's like no the other guy one thing you
can't fake is the ability to like
he can read one of those books and then
he could pair it to you really yes which
is very like
that's a lot of life coaches or it's
hard life coaches
i'm sure he's still killing it is life
coaching like a pyramid scheme
or is there a genuineness in it the the
problem with life coaching is if you
like even anthony robbins right he's
amazing but i don't know exactly
he has so many good tips so many good
things that you can learn from but a lot
of life coaches but even with anthony
robbins what do you what do you know him
from other than life coaching nothing
nothing right so we don't know what even
com he's accomplished before a lot of
life coaches read books and then they
start parodying like he said all that
stuff and then people are like oh that
makes sense but it's not your own
thoughts it's a newspaper yeah it's not
what you created yeah it's all like you
know just repeating other things which
is cool yeah but if you're a life coach
you should probably be like a
multi-millionaire that has accomplished
a bunch of stuff instead of just like
teaching people how to do it if you
haven't done it yourself tony robinson
or tony robbins is an interesting one
because like like you said he's
this has been his career but there's
also something
to emulate when he's able to like
package it so nice and clean and make it
like he's crazy sustainable and like i
don't know he's got people paying him
tens of thousands to go on retreats for
a weekend and [ __ ] uh i fell in love
with them i love john wooden and he had
there's out there there's an hour
interview of tony robbins and john wood
and that's like my favorite talk
probably on i don't know who john wood
is
the wizard of westwood he coached ucla
basketball for like 60 years oh he just
is really empathetic too and like great
at connecting with people so like when
he's in crowles he can just he has that
ability you know did you ever see that
um
god i can't remember the exact thing but
there was a big controversy he almost
got canceled because the way he was
talking to some woman in the crowd
she came to his retreat or whatever but
i think she was like in an abusive
marriage or something and he was like
yelling at it
multiple times is that one or not yeah i
think so
i'm getting this but i feel like he was
like saying it's your fault you need to
get out of it kind of thing right
everybody blew up in arms but it's like
if you go to some place and you're like
go give me [ __ ]
knowledge experience hard they want that
yeah
he didn't run up through her on the
street
yeah she went there
but he was he was awkward in his i don't
know if it's the newest netflix thing
that he did but he was just he's
saying the f word so many times i'm like
it's a little bit try you're
like shocking like it didn't fit a man
who cussed doesn't have the words to say
what's on his mind malcolm x wow
powerful maybe i heard denzel washington
say i asked malcolm mexico
so i'm not sure if it's a right and most
comedians also say like that's their
go-to if it's not working out well they
they'll cuss
yeah yeah it helps yeah
well and in songs too like you can add
cuss words and songs when you can't like
think of other words to put in there
yeah so everybody go check out andrew
[Music]
and follow every single word he says
we're all disciples and in complete
agreement
uh with his thought process
jk
uh so we talked about our king and
distinct trivia contest uh we solicited
we want people to submit see say why
they're going to be the biggest
solicited uh king and the sting super
fan
you don't have to make it weird that's
just a normal weird word to use in that
situation all right uh but uh
if your mind's in the gutter uh
you've been soliciting chin recently not
me i've been drawing that's why i hear
it get triggered we need ari man is here
to
shed more light in that both his last
appearances he gave us like hooker
stories uh he brought to the county
store and then he was in tijuana which i
realized after that was really funny
theme with him but king in the sing
superfan contest we got a bunch of
submissions
uh christian went through them i have
not seen them no one in here has seen
them except christian so we're gonna
watch like a few of the maybe maybe
five six and then we'll watch them next
week and uh then we'll eventually
whittle it down and create our
tournament of the people we're gonna
play
and do they have questions that they're
already being asked or like what is this
submission so right right now
uh we're gonna whittle this down to
four or eight people and it's more based
on like your enthusiasm like are they
real super fans yeah we're not picking
the eight people off the most
knowledgeable
it's like the most enthusiastic show if
you want to be in it and then from there
those eight people you'll have to be the
most knowledgeable among them to win it
and the championship is going to be on
regular king and the sting uh to be a
commercial for this show
that's okay
i was just picturing you gambling on the
side of those contestants oh i would he
probably is
once we meet him we can put out uh live
odds i'll take action
we need a website to put stuff in escrow
nick tate
nick tate
[Laughter]
uh all right let's watch this guy all
right this ain't his name is rahaji r
raheed i'm not sure how to pronounce it
and i wish i didn't micro attempt it
oh we can't hear you no
you can't hear it nope
but already you could hear it in your
headphones yeah and it's not only the a
down it's not it's not
both of them are halfway
um
uh maybe
it should be on a headphones on the
shallow house sound right yeah not hdmi
matrix the reason i knew him with the
banana hand yeah yeah should be going a
headphone jack okay
that's not do you remember that movie
[ __ ] remember but i don't remember the
banana it was the elevator scene
he gets stuck in an elevator with tony
robbins and tony robbins gives him oh
now i get it yeah wait is tony robbins
the one that shocked him out of it he's
the one that put him into it right into
it yeah he's put him into it because he
went to a life seminar thing with really
i don't remember that he's like snapping
or something
yeah and he had to tail yeah yeah
dude that big toe thing is hilarious on
there yeah one of my friends is like
that like if a girl's big toe is longer
he's like i can't do it you're kidding
that movie made me realize i'm way more
than willing to jump on any bullet
i was like these women ain't that bad
two candles she has one big toe or two
big toes no my my friend toe next to
their big toe is longer than their big
toe oh
so
yes i don't want it shallow how long is
a good jack black movie back in the day
i had tony robbins in it yeah and
gwyneth paltrow looked so good so in
that movie
fell in love with her pounds i was into
it i was into that version i was 500
pounds
[Laughter]
now i got here and i just look like this
you're beautiful yeah you look gorgeous
gorgeous
sugar rashad evans told me i was very
handsome i just wanted a handsome dude
you're multi-talented too you could sing
i believe uh any man named sugar on
another man's lips
mostly please don't ever but i mean it's
still here it still means handsome
though yeah it still means handsome yeah
uh
my favorite line from shallow hal he
meets the hawaiian guy
and just out of nowhere he goes oh man i
saw a hawaiian guy try to play hockey
once it was funny as [ __ ]
just like i don't remember that
he just like blurted it out that movie's
great
i rewatched uh school of rock not too
long ago still a classic orange county
yeah
what's that when we were kid the kid not
a girl
saving silverman yeah yeah he's so
[ __ ] good in that too uh arleigh
ermey was in that the guy from um
full metal jacket like the the older guy
yeah the older oh he talked about this
sorry sergeant guy i just love that guy
yeah he was awesome i feel like i've
told the story now that he said we
talked about it
i love that guy it keeps coming up
it's authentic and i just saw him in a
uh another older movie the other day
seven he was in seven oh such a good
movie
still in washington
all right let's try to play this guy
again all right so who's this guy
rahasha
yeah
exactly
so i hear you guys are looking for some
king in this thing super fans um i i've
categorized myself as one a couple
reasons three reasons first reason is
i'm part of the patreon which is easy
dope uh second reason one of twenty i
didn't say the emerald
i am one of the only ones
so i can't say the name i'm a halfer
the third reason pretty good reason here
i got a good
rack
dude that qualifies but still
uh yeah i'm a huge fan of up to this
trivia and kill it so uh please pick me
please
get out of pennsylvania okay
now are they thinking that
they just get we fly i this is pretty
freaking talk to uh the king in the
sting crew because i said okay this is
not confirmed and i said it on air i
said if i can get it approved i would
like to have the winner behind the
culture corner nice uh weird no all the
early rounds will be zooming in
and i think we'll like look at these
people and decide which ones we want in
but we can also give automatic bids and
attach a rat king tattoo
he's in you're in
you're in you're in rahish
this guy's name is michael josek
i've seen this gentleman before
submitting my video to
the cats after dark because i have a
shot at winning this i feel like he has
his hand on the bottom screen
yeah yeah is he a nurse or is that looks
like a nurse
you don't take or something like that
yeah anyways how am i trying to go on a
date with somebody's fans of this show i
feel like you've um
been a fan for a couple years now never
really missed any podcasts i got
notifications on my youtube spotify
patreon shout out to all those patreon
members
um
i've been on the show three times now
okay big accomplishment in my opinion
and um hopefully you know i can get
flown out there if i win this trivia
um
i gotta get you nurse and then there's
for nine years
last trouble kind of important
we'll see what happens
wow
but yeah going on what brow said he was
saying uh he was saying that he was a
traveler he was an icu nurse for nine
years and now he's a travel years uh
nurse for the past two i think he said
okay fair enough uh he was good i love
the enthusiasm i think he could have had
a better woo
i think he could have had a better video
where he just like waited till he was
off work and did that whisper possibly
i think he saw it and he was like i'm at
work i got to do this right now he acted
on it
he's at work with a nurse
that i like i also just want to talk to
him because i just love [ __ ] travel
nurses are making [ __ ] bank right now
they make like eight grand a week it's
absurd travel nurses yeah and he wants
us to fly here and i see you too that's
that's
yeah he's probably that guy's probably
he's probably got a lot of flight miles
he's flying himself out
well
maybe
no i got i'm i should find it out by
next week um
but i kind of like the contest with a
little like loosey-goosey
will we fly us out
uh
we hire so many fans
good submission this is fun i like this
i like him
yeah well you like him oh
i want to see if anyone recognizes her
uh hey guys it's amanda jesus plot
[Applause]
i know i could win
i've been watching guys's show for like
i don't know going on three years now so
let's give it a whirl
right to the point i think she has to
play the show's only channel
she really should have referenced uh the
whole stevie situation and that would
give points i mean we know but uh like
just to add some gravitas to the video
good i also think
that you just have a way better chance
of being in the competition if you're a
girl so she's automatically in we're not
gonna no we're not gonna say she's
automatically in but i think she's
probably it right uh yeah yeah good
morning
what's up father george come in time for
the pastry mod
no not yet
sorry
that actually is really good timing
did i come in time for the magic moment
gosh just in time two more have some
right here
wow perfect
what is magic mind you're you're
wondering well i guess you haven't been
listening to this show uh magic mind is
the anti-procrastination drink it's a
once daily
shot really a magical elixir to help you
do more and stress less it's made up of
12 natural ingredients echinacea
ashwagandha a bunch of other good stuff
ashwagandha i just heard you know how
like heroin you take some oh yeah and
you know
yeah
that was that was random but yeah it
looks directly out of it yeah okay
random come on
supposedly the more you take the more
you need to get high ashwagandha
it's an adaptogen so actually the more
you take it the less you need for your
body to feel the effects i don't know
how that works wow but science yeah
science that's awesome uh that's one of
the benefits or one of the natural
ingredients it's only 30 milligrams of
caffeine but it gives you a nice with
all the alchemy of the other natural
ingredients it gives you a nice focused
zen hum throughout the day uh so you
don't have the anxiety when you're
starting to task uh go to matchmind.com
dark promo code dark for 20
off and uh start knocking stuff off your
to-do list that's magic mine dot co
slash dark promo code dark for 25
percent off cheers
and ashwagandha is good for sex through
that my mouse sex yeah cheers was that
uh last ingredient
sex i forgot about it sounds like
something uh you say before uh flying
into a building or something
oh my god george
just saying i'm just saying i made it
about sex and you made it about
something horrible
yeah magic mine is a positivity drink
but that was pretty
yeah i need giggles
play the song
yeah play the dance i have almost no lie
but i don't know if that's in
no personal bar
i don't know if james would like that
one uh
ashwagandha though it's in like
every one of these like natural like uh
athletic greens organifi they all
they're all used in ashwagandha
it's it's popular it must be some good
[ __ ] it's an aphrodisiac it is i just
saw some uh twitter thread and it was
like
like essentially ways you wouldn't think
of that people have made a fortune and i
feel like ashwagandha is one but it was
stuff like oh
velvet supplier in the 80s and then they
got velour as one of their their people
or people rehabbing like heavy machinery
equipment the pop socket the guy who
made the uh iphone top socket
i don't know where you're going with all
these things but yeah
they are
i had i i explained it if you listen
back
just weird ways to make money that you
wouldn't know that have made people a
wealthy beyond i always think of the
frisbee when i think of stuff like that
yes pet rock
yep so what is uh what's going on i got
filmed in early oh yeah so we are doing
the ultimate king and the sting fan
trivia contest okay uh but to get in you
have to let us know why you think you
are the ultimate king in this thing
there's another girl that she was
automatically into yeah it's a girl yeah
don't play the video because it might
ruin
george coming in straight down
bounce right back
i go to sleep with candace thing on my
tv
every single night do you pause it for a
second
welcome to the contest
all right we just pick all girls to be
able to sleep
i cannot tell you how many times i've
seen every single episode
um i've always been too nervous to
submit a video but it's all right here i
am uh everyone in my family knows and my
friends all my friends know how
absolutely obsessed i am with the
girlfriends guy friends what are we
talking about
that's so cool um i got to meet him in
dallas
best day of my entire life
yeah i just feel like i would do
fantastic with king and this thing
trivia to get through theo you got to go
through us
welcome to cuts after dark it is
honestly a g i gotta pat myself on the
back genius move for nubbies
[Laughter]
it's just all feeds into each other but
yeah welcome to the contest what was her
name i don't care yeah it doesn't mean
no no texas texas what's your name
um sarah i believe sarah i think yeah
does she look like a sarah with an eight
waiter with uh no h h i'm getting uh no
h vibes i think i tweeted one time oh
you're right you're right i was right
all right so meatball's right
uh i think sarah's without a nature
always [ __ ] i think she has an h
she's wholesome what does she have can
you say i don't think she had an h let
me i mean i can go to the email hang on
i may even cut out what i said you
slutty's just a harsh word
but in 2012
that's all right i'll steal your joke
sorry that should be the next segment
going through uh nick's old tweets
that's a good segment that's a good sign
nick tweets i think i think the the
segment nick loses a job
i love actually going through anybody's
like old social media knowledge right
now you're active on it we can
blur this out right nick huh we can blur
this out right yeah all right what is it
and it would not even put it on a screen
at this point
yeah that's what yeah with no h that's
okay and then we got one more and then
we'll show we'll show then rest the next
episode so
we'll end really well
oh yeah this is going to end in 2025. we
we had like a lot of good submissions so
i just want to make sure that they all
get shown so and it really is we do a
fair shake here
let's put it up it's like number three
that we
very natural are we voting on them to
get into this yeah i think we can all i
think i think after we see him we can
all pick but like
okay we can just shoot people in if if
we're like okay yeah that's just money
and then if we get to eight that's all
right got it okay
we got we yeah we should be able to
we'll be fine yeah now yeah
i feel a sob story
sorry about that yeah
i've been with you guys since the
beginning fighting the kid this past
weekend
everything pretty much episode one
really appreciate all the work you guys
do um
yeah i've since i've been hearing so
much of it i'm sure i know a thing or
two this could be lots of fun i'm also
going to be in la uh
the second week of august so it could be
convenient to sit in on a show
anyways um thanks for listening
he's already doing his plugs like you do
at the end i'm gonna be in l.a yeah
he's a good fit he's going to be on it
okay okay
u-haul trucker yeah was he submitting
and driving is that i think he was
writing it sound like it was on the
trucker the car was on gambling
so that's our four contestants can you
take down the uh
uh
just so like when the there's not a
video up it's the background yeah
do you want you no yeah you guys want to
watch one more or not i say
how many how many was that four that we
watched i think two more because then
you said we have 12 right there was
three uh that was five okay one more all
right one more um any girls no wasn't
that just four
no i showed uh the first guy whose name
i couldn't pronounce the nurse and then
the two hot girls and then that guy
yeah yeah
two girls back to back hot girls um i'll
just play this one
can i get huh huh
what
what's this guy said the same guy the
same guy
that's why i wanted it i didn't want to
say it because i didn't know if i
was being a little
inconsiderate or
this is my audition take 45 reasons why
you should be in the car oh is this the
same guy
yeah it's singing
i love that we don't know he's the same
guy for sure
i remember what sarah looks like but
that's the same with this guy he did his
hair this time the fact he's been doing
it since christmas like it's all
different he's like he said he was a fan
for like years wait so he said his name
was derek in that one i forgot what it
was
hey cat's crew i'm auditioning to be on
the trivia oh it doesn't say his name in
this one but his the reason why they're
two different uh side by side dude it's
the same guy
option alan
okay cool okay but he even said cats
after dogs i do not think it is i don't
think it is either you guys are crazy
you guys are out of your mind
that's the same guy he's even his voice
i'm an audio engineer it's his voice
okay fine i'm standing wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait it's fine
i'm staying impartial because i'm cocky
[Music]
you don't have the emails that they came
from it came from a different email
that's why this one's name is diego and
this one's names i have two emails are
they twins if they're twins that'd be
awesome and they're all different we
should have them they have to be they're
in your mind okay
where's the vote
if these are one person i don't want
them on the show but if these are two
people we need to have them back yeah
yeah then maybe we bring them on they're
awesome
before first round match up
hang on
i'm going to the emails are the same guy
just get two screens okay who's who
uh do you think they're the same person
i wanna believe it's two different
people but it's one guy yeah you think
i'm starting to think it might be twins
that'd be awesome
george
you think it's one or two people george
i feel like i don't know they came from
different emails and
the fact that we're even really george
i'm going with two different people
because you want to do it just to have
fun
if it's from two different emails i
think it's twins
so that locking in the answer this was
um
where is it wait christian what do you
think
i have no idea just look at that this is
[ __ ] me up looking at their faces and
their voices
i wanna say like i feel like they could
be twins okay did any of them leave
their number i need a con so the same
guy
the one where they he doesn't say his
name
is this is his email where he doesn't
say his name we can't see it though but
yeah
that's a weird ass emo oh i see this app
see that it is does look like a company
email or something which is why it would
be like you would have to kind of
he's sent from his work he's trying to
stuff the ballot boxes yeah uh he's got
to change it up he's a russian and then
where's the other one
it was diego right yeah
well we'll uh reveal the answer next
week
after a little bit more research uh
you're convinced you have no question
are you joking what do you think really
i swear to god i think that could you
are the quick time still up
um
yeah
i'm sorry
you think they're
honestly nick
not for numbies do you think this is i
swear to god the one guy has
i'm a big browse guy leave the bit
inside what do you think
browsers browse i know browsers okay the
eyebrows are identical that's how you
gotta look oh [ __ ] and by the way but
he got a haircut he sent in too i don't
understand it
christmas time he barely got a haircut
but this was just sent in oh maybe he
doesn't take down his decorations he did
you change after a little while and he
says any well because he was talking
about the christmas decorations it's
like christmas halloween it looks like
oh my gosh did he send in an old
submission that he did is he a time
traveler what's this yeah that was an
old time traveler i don't like let me
see what he said let's see what like
this is my audition take 35 reasons oh
did you say diego twice or not oh it
sounds oh his audition for the culture
corner yeah that was a long time ago i
thought he was just referring he has two
different ones i thought that's what he
was referring to in like sitting in
after the contest got it his eyebrows
were thicker when he auditioned for the
culture corner the fact that it's a year
apart makes a lot more sense which i did
not realize at the time i thought these
were two new submissions for the new
trivia game i was like why would you do
that right there were two different
emails
this makes more sense he looks slightly
different he just looks slightly
different but i still want to believe
they're twins
two different people yeah i'm just gonna
say they're twins
i'm changing after you know seeing the
different email was kind of like a like
you said business email that it's uh and
the other one was a year ago this was we
did a whole contest to be in the culture
corner and audition and that's what he
was showing us that he had applied
before
all right so this will be the last one
we'll play that you need to clarify but
that's dedication yeah he's been going
since christmas yeah years i he took up
a ton of real estate in my head i feel
like he should be in but i still want to
check it out this guy looks like billy
football for pmd
i was just about to say he looks like a
like midwest high school football player
midwest darren till hey cass crew look
at that haircut i'm from north carolina
and i'm applying to be on the ultimate
trivia game
this is my wife
she's in this my cat jax he likes ice
cream and my baby is sleeping in that
house looks pretty nice
so again
transition
who's the first man on the moon
lance armstrong
who had been in amazon easy
elon musk
are there more doors and windows
who cares
yeah i just went three for three on some
really hard hitting questions that i
most definitely did not look up
beforehand so
that's why i should be on cash trivia
gang gang buzz buzz
soar
you know what i like him oh yeah i i
that was that was like the most effort
out of any of them put in he was funny
he referenced cat stuff
some cinematography i i would say
cinematography there was a crossfade
transition in there
i i although i people over you
use the crossfade in early editing it
should be like a change a passage of
time smash cut is always better for
comedy yeah there's some mike pops every
time the
you know yeah
yeah he's fired
no i i think
this guy's in
yeah i like everybody cool this guy
doesn't seem sold i like uh george you
can read this like the guy from the
beginning with the tattoo
um
anyone that is a female and that guy
yeah we're going to watch more next week
and then like oh like always
and then i think we can all get one like
once we have
we can all pick our faves can we sponsor
like spawn like this is my guy yeah yeah
i i i think for now i think we've said
three yeah
we'll coach them through it yeah i think
yeah like the voice yeah come down
what i'm trying to think how it works
i'll take it i'll take sarah i'll bite
the bullet i'll take sarah i'll follow
my sword
um
you guys can fight after diego you know
do your thing
i like this we all pick someone that
puts in so all we said people are
automatically in but you are picking
sarah yeah all right i i'm a golden
buzzer on sarah
i can't remember who was the first guy
we said was automatically in
with the tattoo oh yeah tattoo um that
was raheed that you want them to be
yours yeah me and him both got
similar leg tattoos to our podcast
brethren
flexible george
yeah what's up with it bro
sent me a dm and i was like hey shout
out you bro
nice nice
uh i
want the guy who made the edited video
or maybe maybe i should like uh his name
was
i'm gonna wait but yeah
it takes some time to like the people we
mentioned are automatically and are
probably in i don't know yeah this is a
lucy goosey event uh no complaints
considering i might not be here next
week who knows
that's that's the thing about life none
of us or any of us let's not be here
let's not talk about stuff like that
though you know all right that's the
show guys
let's stop that
uh what else do we have what else do we
have to talk about
oh yeah
what is that so uh george and george
started our mma training
nice guys yeah like we actually started
not just the
the little prep class
we actually were doing the damn thing
already missed the day yeah we already
missed the day we had to go had two yeah
food truck diaries yeah shout out one we
love you guys angela lee love you
i wanted to meet her you should have
came in
she was very nice i didn't know
but the training is going well um
we have a brazilian instructor yeah he
teaches us about our guard hey you you
and guard
you know
you hold them close
under alberto crane's lineage
freaking it's awesome
and you guys are doing it like it's like
every day of the week right yeah yeah
five days a week twenty weeks twenty
years twenty damn weeks yes back freak
and then we get our smoker fight for
spell
you guys are both doing it right yeah
yeah you guys are
nuts but that's so dope dude do you have
more details on like the venue or like
because when you say smoker that means
they're selling tickets to it right
isn't that like what is the definition
of a smoker i think it's just like a
legitimate gym fight so it's like like
you know how like sometimes you train
but then like you go hard and you're
like okay we're actually going for it
right now it's like the fight at the end
of an episode of tough yeah basically
and it's all mma right like it's much
less yeah it's wrestling jiu jitsu
uh you know yeah kate wall control going
up and down the cage yeah we're just
starting out basic like stuff now we
won't get gloves until uh week four
before yeah yeah
technique
i did uh two muay thai classes with
chappelle actually and we were like
partners and he [ __ ] me up dude he's
so strong yeah he was kicking me and of
course god he's such a bull though oh
he's oh and he's a he was a cheerleader
he's probably really flexible with
getting yeah yeah
but now i have his shoes so thank you
yeah
you guys are totally different weight
classes too i know i don't know why they
match me up yeah that's crazy dude his
kicks were [ __ ] hurting we say nick
uh no that's hilarious though you're
like i don't know why that messed me up
we came together yeah yeah
they're like this will be funny like
chin
why did he said it
i missed him
[Laughter]
are you
crazy
wow it was hard it was hard but you
can't be together we did what came
afterwards
what
what what's going on it's a hard part it
was hard but you came together yeah it's
a hard fight
[Music]
anyways sing twister words
so george and george
so what weight class do you think you
guys think will you have their the
smokers at
um i think it's like they just try to
match you up with someone around your
size yeah hypothetically not actually i
don't think there's gonna be a cut or
anything just like i think it's just
like hey you're around 200 right fight
this other person around 200 okay and
same skill level yeah yeah basically
yeah that's cool
exciting exciting stuff uh keep giving
us the updates um when you start really
getting physical with each other yeah oh
yeah
so
don't even go there
that one was like yeah that was pretty
blatant
uh
there was something oh i i gotta i gotta
i gotta calculate it but uh next picks
didn't go great last week for the first
time i gave i gave my parlay last week
yeah uh i think it went i know jordan
lost i know
jordan won though
yeah
was a huge favorite but uh i picked him
second round plus 500 which cash
so that made it uh basically a break
even night but uh
way too much money on uh
that wasn't jared van der uh no that was
a couple weeks ago um
oh against uh the guy with the flat face
yes what the hell he's from alabama
he's from alabama
[Laughter]
i just remember like hearing that when i
was growing up and
hey elementary and
people tell me like i've had ladies come
up to me and be like you got a such a
flat face why would they say that though
i think you have my cheekbones people
are rude
people are rude and people are yeah they
don't they're naive dude you have like
high cheekbones you don't have a flat
face though yeah you don't have a flat
face
side profile yeah
yeah do you have are you native american
uh isn't every white person a little
native 25 charity yeah yeah yeah
i'm not everyone's grandma is like oh we
had a
uncle dan and he was a part blackfoot
indian
okay yeah
i blame it on westerns yeah my grandma
loved native american veg
they were honeys that's what she like
any actor she would that she liked like
sean connery here yeah but uh native
american she had a lot of honeys that
were dating right
any native american ufc fighters
um
uh
yes there was one right
someone has
he but he wasn't like ultimate fighter
series and someone called the natives oh
the native psycho jordan griffin
he
he's a duke uh rufus sport mma guy
um
he's had he's had really really exciting
fights
uh okay i know him
i heard someone with a b
a guy with a b in his name
well how about that nickname though
native psycho that is cool
oh yeah
nico montano which has she's had like a
very controversial career but
why
she
got stripped because she refused to
fight valentina yeah she was the first
ever 125 pound uh what was the champion
she won uh tough
when was uh that volunteered
2016 maybe
the seventh picture in on the right
that's the guy that was on the tim next
one right one more next that guy
that he was in the ufc i think for a
little bit
yeah brock b brock weaver oh okay yeah
yeah abraham he was native american
speaking of fighting fought dogs
dogs dogs
dogs dogs like michael vick are like i
think michael vick style fought dogs
oh i know he's been in dogfights
yeah
speaking of fighting i missed last week
you guys fought right we did yeah so who
won
who do you think won no one me
did anyone have no one no no no yeah it
was very pathetic yeah because we didn't
do headshots just body shots all right
you want i was doing no headshots for
you because i didn't want to [ __ ] up
your neck but i told you christian
i had the epidural shot so i can't feel
it anymore so i'm like i'm down to do
whatever oh [ __ ] but now my back is
jacked up however should we spin the
wheel an excuse for next week uh no
let's get oh yeah for next week
i mean
every other week or what uh
maybe every because we want to get
proper gloves because now we don't even
have 16 we have
mma gloves and boxing gloves yeah uh
yeah so i think we bring in regular
gloves next week i do love the
anticipation
of spinning the week before oh
leading up to next week can you add
austin to the wheel yeah and also ask
casey if you would like to be on the
wheel just so i don't sell anybody's
name on this podcast uh
when you google brock weaver dog
fighting the first article that comes up
is brock weaver clears up alleged
dogfighting video quote unquote i don't
have that kind of heart so i they were
castigating
but it's up for debate
i mean just do your own research
yeah it seems like he's innocent yeah if
you don't support dog fighting like
comment and subscribe right now if you
hate dog fighting i want you to go to go
george go right now click subscribe and
comment
wow that's good good plug good plug and
if you don't you love dog fighting so
uh so that's a that's an absolutely
great call uh for i'm gonna put together
another knicks picks parley to lose some
people money
doesn't want to be on it but we also
have to add uh
croatian george on to it i'm in it i
thought he wasn't it
i thought i was here last week
rollerblader they were actually pretty
tough uh i thought he would be in it
yeah
we got he was
pretty
[Music]
much going to be tough
yes did you guys like do rounds or just
have a one little time
also chin if you want to run it back
oh my gosh
unless the wheel says you run it back
whatever you want to do outside these
walls that's fine we would also film and
put it in the first round
the first rule of cats after dark fight
club is definitely talk about talk about
it guys after dark fighting i love you i
don't want to hit him because we let the
wheel outside i love you i don't want to
hit you but if it's going to come down
to it why don't you guys call me out
i've got to hit it this is exactly
because this is the only way
i was disappointed how it went last week
but i calmed myself down i'm like
there's no way it stays that way yeah
people will get pissed
yeah so head shots now right give it
hell
if we rematch it shane we're definitely
doing headshots here we go
is that me oh that's george [ __ ] which
george me i'm gonna project okay
baby
see how that fight camp is going for you
hey brows oh [ __ ] all right that's
actually a great ass competition right
there these two you guys are the same
build essentially all right yeah i was
thinking
i was like if there's going to be one
match up where it's kind of like you
guys both don't do it though we can do
it it doesn't matter if they want to do
it they have to do it now the wheel
spoke the wheel has smoke and the thing
is you can go in the minute and you can
you can agree and both go light if you
want you could do whatever you want in a
minute but
you guys are fighting for a minute
but either way it goes i heard the cats
after dark commission is a little
loosey-goosey so it's all right
well it's gonna be great to have you and
you on commentary with these two
let's get it back i heard a lot of good
love for you yeah are you competitive
yes he is yeah i i'm competitive all
right oh snap so vlog vlog your training
camps this week and we'll play like cut
it down to like maybe a minute and a
half again and we'll okay we'll play on
the episode nick but you're like you're
like training right now you're doing the
thing are you good are you like what's
your what would you say what's my what
what's your like style
uh i'm not gonna give it up to you what
do you mean
all right you almost had press
conferences
just because i played basketball with
him uh i i would say at this moment i'm
lying at like minus 200.
oh all right
were you an athlete in like high school
and stuff he's really like
oh
you're i don't know
but i haven't i'm not like a huge
fighter yeah i'm not bad i hold myself
off of my knowledge of the guy i'm
you know i feel like nick just like
championed you so now i'm gonna champion
george go for it my guy george here you
guys are training partners we are
training partners you know we're in the
same camps one would say uh
i would have to give it a
you know minus 350 to george damn
multiple years of boxing experience oh i
didn't know that okay yeah you weren't
supposed to tell that [ __ ] oh schnapps
dang are we doing headshots or just body
shots you guys you guys that's up
you guys decide okay whatever you want
we'll we'll have fun with it yeah all
right or it'll be we don't have time
headshots right yeah just kidding all
right yeah
next time you are you and i have for
headshots without a doubt is that that
the undercard i'm gonna [ __ ] your neck
up again
second time i have no boxing experience
but you did a muay thai class i did two
muay thai classes chapel kicked me
really hard and i left
how tall are you six one i'll tell you
six i say six two i might be uh close to
closer to six one i don't know i think
both you need to stand up i don't
believe that oh i don't believe that
stan good call
i think you're taller than me for sure
you should record this oh [ __ ] oh yeah
which one of you guys are lying together
hold on guys wait let me record this
is the ground underneath let's get a
picture too
dude you're way bigger than i ever
[ __ ] this
[Music]
lonely
ladies and gentlemen this is crazy
from calabasas
california
this is
cass after dawn
oh yeah my eardrums blew up but that was
uh that was actually really good i'm
gonna have to i need like a week of
training like i need someone to actually
what's actually a week george
uh if you continue to announce for us
you should say it's time until bruce
buffer uh sends us a cease and desist
first off wait no one else can say it's
time for his autograph yeah he's got he
he uh i probably in a fight setting but
he does have it
patented i am uh he charges
yeah he does a lot of cameo uh cameo
things uh christian i'm texting you a
picture do you have imessage on your
computer i do yeah uh this is i'm
texting you my next picks oh
i like it i just i just put it together
oh on the fly
next pics it really helps crystallize
your thoughts when you just have to do
it on the spot because i've obviously
been looking at the card for weeks but
uh you just never oh this is london too
this is an amazing car and i love early
morning cards i don't know uh so good i
think they the prelims start at 9am our
time amazing coffee and some prelims of
people you don't know that well i love
it uh yeah me too so we got mason joe
there's a lot of chalk on here but i
don't know mason i feel like is going to
run through ludovic klein that actually
i don't know i'm not going to bet on
that one straight up but honestly kind
of a bad bat but i just wanted to add
more legs mason jones minus 420 nicholas
dalby minus 250 versus uh claudia silva
silva
uh charles johnson muhammad makayev
under one uh two and a half rounds minus
115. uh makaylev is like a minus 500
favorite yeah he's super good yeah so i
don't want to bet on his money line but
i i think he
so does that mean
does that mean like you
don't have like a
clear bet on who wins right it's just
under the fight just ends in under two
and a half minutes yeah and there is a
way i think uh mikayev could just
wrestle him for three rounds but i think
more likely rear naked or
i think charles johnson is really really
fast hands he he honestly could knock
him out so
that's minus 115 mac wanna miracani i'm
going to be so heavy on mac one and
miracani probably round one and by sub
plus 550 plus 300 plus 150 on this uh
under two and a half for vulcan and paul
craig to some people this is gibberish
some people enjoy it tom aspen on minus
140 200 to win 3 800.
let's ride
let's go and i really think if you just
did though i like doing the parlay
because to jen and you can make the bank
but i think if you bet on those fights
individually uh you'll come out who's
makwan fighting um jonathan pierce uh
i've never heard of him he's he's a
really good grappler too he says what he
does is uh uh parking lot jiu jitsu he's
just like
he's just man he man handles people and
[ __ ] but i think he's gonna put his neck
out there and gets up
i'll have a little on jonathan pierce
round two round three because
maquon will uh mr wonderful
will gas himself out can you go to the
topology page of makawanamirakani it's
the funniest fighter stop photo there is
have you ever seen this
oh man it's it's hilarious and he does
youtube videos of him just eating fruits
i didn't know that what he's like oh
like like an apple anything yeah
an apple i just
um
i take out the wells yeah
how are you feeling about uh monkey king
versus paddy to batty
that's a good question dude yeah i uh
are you going for the twerker or the tea
bagger i want the tv bag i want the tea
bigger to win i i i'm nervous i won't
have any money on the fight because i
think like i don't know it's a little
closer to you
can you say tea bag again
i say stuff
weird bagging the midwest
yeah it sounds like you said it
i've always said las vegas weird i think
i said it okay there but yeah that was
good right there yeah
new segment
new segment let's make fun of people's
speech impediment
let's start with the no-fly zone yeah
yeah you guys been making fun of me the
entire time uh but did we get to macwa
on stage yet this is his topology
the picture the photo
yeah he's hilarious how did he copy and
paste the same girl three times
and last fight i was on him saw round
one he hit it he's the man but if he
doesn't get it he gasses it's kind of a
very binary result
um that was fun i the the culmination
should have been the wheel but i wanted
to get nick's picks in there
uh any oh go out with plugs thick boy
now has a daily mma news show
tbfn thick boy fight network check it
out big boy fight news i think oh yes
yeah sorry but it is on the network but
it is fun
you know
when was this slap oh yeah that dude on
the left
uh i think it was just uh
i mean it's so obvious oh july 3rd
the banksy or banks no
t-mobile arena
when i see stuff like this i'm like it's
so obviously like pre-planned
i don't think it sounds like nate
doesn't play yeah i don't think it was
did you just do it to me i think is that
just it oh he's like that dude it looks
like he's leaning in kind of before yeah
he said
i don't know but why
but that's pretty gangster though like
you're gonna get slapped how's will
smith gonna smack better than you
tell me
now i'm actually a little suspicious the
way he like it looked like he almost
like tried to slap his own hand to make
it look like he did slap it but it was
bad it was like yeah
we work in this industry we know what's
going on these days i don't know i just
like to think yeah nick diaz would just
slap someone if he doesn't like what
they're saying
personally i think if diaz can t uh keep
kamiyah from taking him down and keeping
him off the ground even though he has a
good jujitsu and if he can keep it a
straight striking match i got diaz
because diaz has a [ __ ] chin like no
other so he'll go down on his [ __ ]
he'll keep throwing until someone calls
it
he's going to get [ __ ]
i don't know though rory mcdonald took
an atheist down seven times
and hardcore yeah yeah like destroyed
him yeah chris benoit
what does nate walk at oh he's a weird
reference i love crispin what weight
does he need i heard he walks at 190.
that's what i heard
that's the 90. yeah 190. walking at 190.
so if you're coming to 170 that's not a
huge deal kind of 155 it's not a big
deal daddy was watching 155 that's
pretty that's a big
i could cut to 165 right now
like a week or two what are you right
now should we do that for cats
what 200 yeah you uh you i've done it
before you
i'd put 500 on it let's do it but wait
what's the date what date are you saying
you can how's how fast i say two weeks
you said one week you said you said a
week a week yeah so all right a week is
over
we have stuff coming up we have a san
diego coming up that's why i'm like i'm
gonna eat okay it's crazy money's on the
table hey man
nick after monday monday i'll cut 20
pounds no no you said 165 right how much
do you like but i have to do stuff on
san diego what how much we can pick i'm
like 197 this is a negotiation i want to
put some money
trying to get the juices flowing
how about
15 pounds
that's yeah i don't even know that's a
lot more i could do that how about you
how about more weight loss
between the two of you guys yeah away in
just literally just pounds right huh
just pounds not like yeah
you guys produce the two biggest shows
here if we lose
i don't want you withering away to
nothing we have shows coming up you
gotta keep your energy up
i'm all good i've done it so many times
nobody was this concerned this is a good
bet
most poundage lost yeah and how long
though uh
seven days like
what not like a month right
i kind of like the idea of doing it like
two three weeks okay just because it's
like cut rather than the
diet but diet is also part of it yeah uh
i i guess do you want to do how about we
just pick a date yeah i was going to say
september 1st
it's
six weeks it's like a fight dude i'm so
down
september first how many pounds lost in
six weeks
because it is like you're also
committing to like being miserable which
i will do
but but it's like i got to bet to the
lead hey it worked for me
that's all that's that's more than a
month so that's
six weeks yeah how about we up the 500
thing to like 600 then six weeks 100
bucks a week
but we're not waiting every week what's
up we're not waiting every day no the
end of the day yeah we'll weigh in
we'll weigh in the next time we see each
other there it is yeah on the scale
and then we'll see who who loses the map
the most amount of pounds oh so 600.
that this is good how much do you weigh
right now do we have a scale here
i think i think i'm probably like 203
but dude he's heavier than me that's
[ __ ] crazy same height no you're
taller maybe i'm 195 i don't know he's
taller who's taller where about how dare
you i think nick's a little better than
you the same height at least
all right chin how much do you want this
is getting too long to edit let's get
our plugs george what do you got uh i
love this though that's that's fun
that's fun it's gonna be good
nothing really but if you guys want to
follow me on instagram
nick puts them in the link to bio but
whatever you guys want yeah yeah there
we go
got a plug i just dropped a music video
it's out now featuring austin awake who
was on the show a couple weeks ago
we flew to arizona filmed it it's called
arizona we like rode around on utvs
floated down salt river 115 degrees but
the video came out cool so that's out
now arizona go stream that run up the
video that's a dope video but even doper
song oh yeah no it's cool catchy one get
it bro damn 45 48 000 views yeah that's
on his youtube channel he's got like
still that's badass okay
look at you
shout out to brendan for sending the
merch through we rocked all that [ __ ]
dude in 21 hours what yeah genuinely
brendan has been playing it about
non-stop around the office that's no not
lying let's go uh he'll be on his phone
and i'll just hear arizona playing i'm
like oh [ __ ]
yeah crystallia cry
that was
all the walls coming down i know
so me and this yeah i mean this kid like
we have a whole project coming out
together and it's kind of just good vibe
like kind of like acoustic style [ __ ]
like this just easy to listen to and i'm
excited for it
so dope dude that that was a dope shot
yeah there's some cool shots the whole
thing then the whole video looks awesome
we rode those things around the utvs are
so fun the can-am dude
especially if you go on back trails yeah
like it's super cool we were out there
for a couple hours it's hot as [ __ ] so
like this part where we were filming all
this [ __ ] it was a farm we went there
during the day and saw some goats
and then we just jordan and yeah yeah
well we kept saying like there's already
enough goats here we don't want it
anymore but
we just ended up filming there because
there was like cool locations and stuff
um
but yeah we got some cool drone shots
and [ __ ] dude these shots are bad is
that a rad desert serpents out there
yeah
so go check it out arizona it's on
youtube it's on spotify
sweet
that's speaker's [ __ ] lexi uh
yeah
nick plug uh another podcast show uh
some really fun episodes i can't think
of any specifics but uh
how's the news oh i talked about monkey
pox uh i explained i explained how to
have sex on monkey pox uh as as guided
by the cdc
it's not a joke not personal if you go
to cdc.gov they give you notes on if you
must have sex on
with monkey pox this is what you do so
we kind of went through some of those
another podcast show check it out lots
more fun stuff there out can you give us
one tip of like what you should do uh
well they suggest um possibly staying
clothed and just pulling out through the
fly
uh not a joke uh or masturbating from a
safe distance apart
yeah mutual masturbation uh from a safe
distance if you go to sex clubs
try to remain this is on the cdc website
if you attend sex clubs
it's [ __ ] bad [ __ ]
uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah so another podcast show
and below deck obviously and bachelor
yet
so for me it's just uh chinsuyi youtube
instagram and also i mean austin
wait before i say that me and into the
am our shirts coming out our collab
shirts coming out oh yeah i think this
month the end of this month i'll let you
guys know all that stuff but it's nice
me and austin are doing concerts
the first one we're doing is
ohio yep august 26 friday portsmouth
ohio me chin austin awake will be there
performing the video uh mer this guy
murphy who's like american idol uh dude
he's got like a pretty cool fan base
he's going to be there
and yeah tickets are available soon me
and channel be headless yeah we'll post
it instagram portsmouth ohio
it's like i've heard of it yeah you've
heard it yeah yeah yeah
he's like yeah
it's my it's basically my hometown so
like every year we do like a little
homecoming show now it's turning into
dope last year was cool it's gonna be
like your sound set uh
it's rhyme sayers in minneapolis like
yeah it's like an ant it's gonna be your
festival and just grows every year yeah
that's what we're trying to do last year
we had like probably three four hundred
people out there and this year it's a
thousand cap venue so we're trying to
just pack it out and do a big show come
out if you're from ohio or if you're not
or kentucky
dude last year people were coming from
all over it was kind of crazy yeah
canada was there i was like shouts out
let's go we're gonna give all
our all yeah so
did you give yours oh you just did it
you have yours uh
anybody not go me uh speaking of shirts
as chin was just saying uh the podcasts
that i work for uh you already know just
dropped their own merch wine oh yeah for
sale soon so make sure to check it out
the podcast and the merch if you'd like
and then just instagram uh see palo 6
oh yeah oh yeah fun show fun show uh
next week george
yeah
sorry we can only do headshots from now
on
so shout out to jack shore oh yeah he
wanted to come on but he can't make it
on today but so hopefully tomorrow or no
sorry not tomorrow yeah
yeah yeah uh
valiant fight could have went either way
at any point
yeah he got hit but his equilibrium went
off he didn't he just oh yeah yeah his
legs weren't under it's understandable
and it happens it happens he's still a
[ __ ] killer he's the killer and he
it's nice when the like
because his competition it was just
getting harder and harder he was getting
a bunch of guys that didn't have name
value but like teamer valve so tough so
yeah really good but now he's gonna
probably get someone who's
he's gonna wipe the floor with i think
yeah a little confidence boost he's the
man he'll yeah
he's got the right attitude i wanna see
him fight brian keller
[Music]
yeah shout out jack short yeah for sure
all right we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you